on the first day of the second week of
his trial for domestic abuse ryan giggs
heard the version of events of the only
other person in the house with him and
his then girlfriend on the night he's
alleged to have assaulted them both
the incident involving kate greville was
witnessed by her younger sister emma
kate greville had texted her to say she
was planning to end the relationship
with the star that night and to ask for
help packing at the home the couple
shared they argued and scuffled about
phones and the custody of the dog emma
told the court she found them on the
floor
she told the jury she saw mr giggs on
top of her sister from her facial
expression she said i could see she was
in pain she put her arms around the
former footballer's waist to try to lift
him off her sister and as he stood up
she said his elbow touched her jaw it
was done in a get off me manner she said
it was force force enough to make me
remove my hands
he'd gone from annoyed to extremely
angry she said he put both his hands on
kate's shoulders and with lots of force
used his head to headbutt her in the lip
she fell to the ground screaming and
covering her face afterwards he told me
it was my fault he'd headbutted kate and
turned to me and said i'll headbutt you
next
her version of events was challenged by
the council for mr giggs who says any
contact was accidental emma greville
admitted that her boyfriend had tipped
off a newspaper about the incident and
that a photographer had arrived before
the former footballer was arrested that
night
the final witness of the day was a
neighbor of ryan giggs who he'd called
on for help that night when he said his
girlfriend had accused him of seeing
other women the neighbor told him oh
ryan not that again
he denies the charges and the case
continues greg milam sky news manchester